[Music]
wow
andy's a little scaled michael goes on
to criticize andy's baby voice but says
nothing about the much more egregious
sin of referring to yourself in the
third person
andy have a booboo tummy would you
rather me
say hey guys my irritable bowel syndrome
is flaring up
okay crazy diarrhea happening right now
you know there is a middle ground
between baby talk and over sharing me no
know what that is bowel can do it after
i finish emptying this musky smelling
pustule on my cracked heel truly it
smells like skunk wafting out of satan's
[ __ ] we're also on record as saying
widow it'll footy woodies num nums
jammies make boom boom
widdicous and woad island to be fair to
andy i do believe this is how to
properly pronounce vermont well if we're
complaining a lot of people think your
albus voice is annoying
yes but have you written your complaints
onto blue note cards because apparently
that matters
well thank you thank you a lot that's
what it's worth i think your baby voice
is topped
thank you miss joe alpress
there's a bunch of sent emails that just
say delivered should i delete those
for the record i have not watched the
episodes since the last one i send
because i had better things to do
including waxing my surfboard feeding
the ducks in the park and three part
cheesy tournaments and so i have no clue
why jim is in his own office and why pam
was recast with the voice of krakow on
sofia the first i just know i don't like
change and therefore i sin
change so we're going for now okay
we used to go for pretty good the
downward trajectory of the office
somehow finds its way into this episode
what's scott's thoughts before this
question is answered let's draw
attention to the very limited space the
staff has to interact with the vending
machine a proper vending experience
requires enough room to stand in front
of the machine
pace a little lean on the glass to check
the numbers reach into your pocket for
change and then squat down before
shoving your arm into the dispensary
phyllis would have had to set her ass on
the table to browse the snack option
since
goddammit someone moved that table so
she can bend like normal people
has it really been 10 years a local
businessman
pledges college tuition to third graders
wait tots refers to the child variety
and not the tater variety the only
reason i agree to watch this is because
i was told it was about andy and dwight
starting a tater tot company called
potato heaven i am even gorging on some
tater tots savory goodness as i
sing and this is just about kids i've
been tattoos
you have to tell them i mean yes
technically he does but does he have to
do it in person this leads to maybe the
most excruciating sequence in an already
excruciating show wouldn't have been
enough torture for michael to call the
principal and have him or her deliver
the bad news
god you know what could this day get any
worse well i still have to finish this
episode and then my wife is making me
finish the milk even though today's date
is on the curtain and oh he's talking
about himself isn't he are those generic
frosted flakes that are called frosted
flakes
is that even legal everyone has been
assigned a random number
since this part essentially becomes the
biggest point of conflict with dwight's
whole scheme i'll point out here how
this makes no sense jim were able to use
this data which i don't believe he would
most certainly find out which employee
each number belongs to before making his
decision and would take himself michael
and probably pam off the contest
entirely in an ideal world i would have
all 10 fingers on my left hand
so my right hand could just be a fist
for punching does dwight realize you
need fingers to make a fist
great graduation she gave a rendition of
when the saints go marching in that
would blow your freaking mind so
michael's been coming back each year to
see how the kids are progressing if
that's the case how did pam not already
know about this
you came into a loss made a promise
rhyming promise with honest
so jim thought it would be ideal if we
all pitched in a 20 for this whole
employee of the month thing the offices
actually make you pitch in your own
money for employee of the month cash
prizes and if your argument is that's
the point then there's no way dwight
could get everyone to do this i mean
kevin's a goddamn accountant
he would have been told first by jim if
there was ever going to be a cash prize
but you mr scott
you are actually doing it hey at what
point would a leader ask for proof of
michael's ability to gift college
educations to a classroom full of
children can anyone walk in and make
this claim without someone questioning
the ability to follow through
asking for a friend but always thought
back to my guardian angel
and the gift that you gave me life sucks
and hard lessons are just about
everywhere these kids are about to learn
the unless the money is cash in your
hand or in your account it's not
dependable money lesson and that truth
can kiss my pimple ridden ass
number nine number nine jim halper
sure everyone can act shocked but isn't
the easy answer here to just say don't
know how i got in the mix there
sorry all let's go to who is in second
place and go down the rank list
simple solutions people does anybody out
there have intuition
i had intuition that watching this
episode was going to be miserable
experience and apparently
i am a full-blown psychic i wanted
to pay for your education i really did
some fans will see michael's desire to
be a good guy and find a way to
empathize with his ludicrous dream of
paying for a dozen educations by
becoming a millionaire i see a lazy
[ __ ] who went to work at a normal job
and just hoped the money would show up
somehow if he really cared for these
kids and he didn't he would have saved
about 50 000 per child
for at least one year of education that
would be 208 dollars a puzzle every day
for 10 years magical millionairing can
happen to a few lucky people but the
real money makers work with grit and
determination
another quality this clown doesn't seem
to have obviously there's been some kind
of a mistake so
why doesn't jim just pick the next
highest score on the list
and oh i see what's going to happen
number two is pam well that's clever
guess i'd better remove that earlier sin
or go to the person in third place and
punch the stupid cake
who promises that to a bunch of kids and
then just doesn't come through like that
satan we're looking for satan so there
was a little bit of a miscommunication
here today
it's been a little wild let me help ease
the pain of a beloved character being
set up and subsequently reamed by
pointing out that when the door closes
the sound should change
unless he's mic'ed up with a lapel which
i did not see
hey mr scott what you gonna do what you
gonna do
pool karaoke the principal told me that
90 of scott's tots are on track to
graduate and that's 35
higher than the rest of the school so 90
of 15 students would be 13.5 so which
poor student did they cut in half like
dewey cox's brother to get that
percentage
i found a copy of it in the copier tray
villain leaves written evidence which
leads to his discovery cliche
i have people skills i am good at
dealing with people can't you understand
it
make sure you click that bell icon but
clicking the little bell icon is how you
make sure you get notified every time we
release a video so click it
you have been talking baby talk
nobody puts baby in the corner you read
that back to me me feel
good body strong sleep big last night
hey guys my irritable bowel syndrome is
flaring up
if you're living with frequent
unpredictable diarrhea and abdominal
pain
you may have irritable bowel syndrome
with diarrhea or ibs d
a condition that can be really
frustrating there you are
there you are peter five minutes ahead
of schedule
right on schedule that doesn't make
sense who does something like that
could it be